this video is not called how to study
for an exam and that's for a reason it's
because I'm not going to sit here
pretend to be a perfect student and tell
you I guess the ideal way to study for
an exam because I think you kind of know
that that involves not cramming and
spending plenty of time to do things
properly
in reality this video is going to be
what studying for an exam more often
than not looked like for me and often
that was not under an ideal situation I
was often stressed cramming trying to
memorize a lot of stuff and I'm just
going to show you what that looks like
and how to make the best of that
situation if you find yourself there I
kind of wanted to make this video as
well stemming from a conversation I had
with a friend who studied law and
thinking about how studying for exams
was different between us for me it
seemed like a lot of doing practice
problems and memorizing equations and
for her it seemed more about reading
large passages of text so I'm just going
to show you what it would look like if I
was studying for an astrophysics exam
and for the point of illustration I'm
going to be pretending to study for an
MIT astronomy exam similar to the one
I've shown on my channel before and
that's based off this course on MIT
OpenCourseWare called introduction to
astronomy the reason I've chosen this is
because the materials that I'm going to
have here today are all publicly
available so that includes some lecture
notes some practice exams and then an
exam itself so assuming I had access to
all of this material at my own
University and I had an exam coming up
very imminently this is what I would do
to start with I would want to have a
look over any lecture notes now
depending on how soon the exam is
depends on how much depth I want to go
into here I definitely don't want to get
bogged down by reading all the notes
available and trying to deeply
understand all of them because that
could be a very time-consuming task with
not necessarily that much payoff at the
bare minimum if the lecturer has
provided any nicely typed up neat note
on say the intranet online I would want
to print those out go through them and
maybe like highlight any essential
things so whether that's some essential
formulas or a few sentences that I think
are like really crucial and then as I'm
doing that if I can gain access to like
a formula sheet or something I'll keep
that with me and I will transcribe any
of these important formulas that I find
an election notes onto this piece of
paper just so that I can keep track of
all the important things I'd only write
down the bare essentials that I think
I'm going to need to know for the exam
and if this had have been a formula
sheet and not just a sheet of constants
then if this formula was already on here
I wouldn't have to write it down again
now this would probably be the minimum I
to be honest wasn't much of a fan of
taking my own notes in lectures in
particularly much detail because I never
found the notes that I took to be very
useful compared to whether it was like
textbook notes or notes that the
lecturer would just provide online
themselves or other relevant information
about the topic and I find it would
often be a waste of time for me to spend
too long taking my own notes so you know
these notes here are just good to get us
kind of in the feel for what was going
on jog our memory of what we actually
learned in this course and have it all
fresh there in our mind while I'm doing
that and finding all of my favorite
things from the lecture notes
I'll also be keeping a running tally of
questions that come up questions that I
need to ask someone about or that I just
know I need to come back to so I'll keep
this sort of list of things that I read
about that I just don't understand what
they do some of these questions will
turn out to have simple answers I just
need to look them up and then I can
cross them off for our last a friend and
I'll explain how to do it some of these
questions I won't get answers to even on
my way into the exam and that's okay
at least I have some awareness of what I
don't know and probably by that point
I've written off the rest of the
questions as being not worth knowing for
the exam I not want to spend any more
than like a quarter to a half of my
study time looking through notes and
reading stuff like this because it's a
very passive activity what I'd want to
spend most of my time on my precious
time before the exam is actually doing
some more active learning and so that is
going to be comprised of looking through
solutions to past exams quizzes and
assignments and also doing the questions
myself so if I am really just getting
started and I need a bit of help what I
would do is print off any solutions to
anything I can find on the internet that
the lecturers provided that I think
irrelevant so if the lecturer has
provided solutions to a past exam or
quiz then that is great and that's going
to be a great starting point I know that
often the advice is to never just read
the solutions to a problem but to be
honest this is not how to be a perfect
student this is how I would study for an
exam and I would always want to have a
look at the solutions before I got
started trying to solve them on my own
because this would sort save me a lot of
time from just doing the wrong methods
and just going about things completely
the wrong way so I print off any of
these I can find and literally just read
through them I had read the question I'd
have a bit of a think about it and I'd
read through the answer making sure that
I knew exactly where every line was
coming from and that I knew what was
going on here by the end of reading
through this page I'd be like yeah sure
I think I know how to do problems of
this type and I do that sort of
throughout here and what you generally
find is the more solutions to these
things you read you see the patterns
coming up and you're like okay I know
the most efficient way to do this and it
gets easier and easier you definitely
don't want to only read other people's
solutions I'm saying this makes a great
start if you're kind of lost and just
don't know the myth
but once you've finished reading as many
answers as you can find or that you need
to start feeling comfortable then it's
time to try a practice exam for yourself
so this could even be one that you know
you have solutions for but you don't
want to look at the solutions yet you
want to just try and go through on your
own you might recognize some of the
problems from things you've already just
been looking at and that's just going to
make this process a bit faster once I've
tried out the exam I'm going to want to
go through and market so this helps if
the solutions are available and if
they're not it means I might have to ask
my friends compare answers there or
maybe even a select row to try and see
if what I'm doing is actually right
working through your own practice
problems is what I think you should
spend the most time doing because it's
definitely in the most effective way to
know what you do and don't know and to
know that you can actually put into
practice I find that just reading
through the lecture notes and
understanding them like sure you could
have an amazing understanding of what
sitting lectures that's not necessarily
going to help you answer these questions
you need to have practiced actually
doing the process and like I said the
more questions like this that you work
through the more patterns you're going
to find and the easier it's going to get
by the time you've gone through a few
practice exams the Kushans might be so
familiar that you don't need to actually
work through each of them you can be
like oh yeah that's just similar to that
one I've seen before and you can be
confident you know how to do that type
of question by this point I will have
acquired quite a large stack of paper
that consists of some of the notes some
of the things I think are important some
of the precipice exams that either I've
filled out my own solutions for or that
I've found solutions for through
somewhere else this is going to become
kind of gold for me to keep everything
fresh in my mind if I'm starting to feel
anxious and losing confidence that I
don't remember how to do a particular
topic or kind of question I'll look
through to find the example I did and
then be like oh yeah yeah I remember how
to do that now and I'll probably carry
this around with me even until I go to
the exam and I
the kind of person that's like an hour
before the exam or even even much closer
I'm like still reading this is that
ideal no some people say you shouldn't
be stressing yourself out like right
before an exam but also right before an
exam is some of the most precious time
to learn information that you're going
to remember and like an hour or half an
hour so it's really up to you I'm not
saying this is the perfect way to study
but this is just what it would look like
for me this is also the type of course
it's like a first year course so a lot
of the questions are formula based or
you actually can quite easily find a
practice examples and solutions and be
you can actually identify patterns
between them because there's lots of
sort of small questions as you get
further into uni like by the time you
get to like fourth year or something the
Smith it might be a little bit more
difficult because the questions I'm each
more involved and maybe there is no
right way to solve each of them it comes
down to being this strange skill of
looking at mathematics and equations and
sort of being able to read them and
understand them rather than reading
large passages of text
I guess it's practicing the art of
reading the minimum information to
understand what's going on trying to
look down through several steps of
working and be like okay I know what's
happening here and I understand the
ideas that are being used here is going
to be really useful for you and I'm
definitely not obsessing over the small
details and the lecture notes that might
not be worth it in the end sure if you
have plenty of time trying to understand
everything but sometimes you have to be
prepared to let go of some details to
you make the best use of the time that
you have left I'm hoping to upload that
sort of special study motivation video
after this one which will be 25 minutes
of me actually slowly working through
this exam and doing those practice
problems like I sort of showed you with
the idea being that you could play that
video while you're doing your own study
for a bit of motivation
someone else is also focusing on
something maybe that will help you focus
too so keep an eye out for that and
thank you for watching also good luck
for any exams that you're studying for
you